foreign
this is a polite decline I'm not going
to say rejection a polite decline when I
via a mutual acquaintance close friend
of mine Jeffrey zarovsky
reached out to see if if you would
participate in my book tribe of mentors
and the beauty was your response ended
up being incredibly valuable as a polite
decline so I I'm going to be
paraphrasing a bit but this this is what
I received
and it was via Jeffrey who was acting as
the the yenta slash intermediary
Jeffrey greetings and thanks for writing
I'm grateful for the invitation to
participate in Tim's next book project
but I'm struggling at this moment to
make time ends meet for all we're doing
at ushg including my ongoing
procrastination with my own writing
projects I thought carefully about this
and it's clearly a wonderful opportunity
but I'm going to decline with gratitude
know the book will be a big success
exclamation point thanks again Danny so
this
is so
noteworthy for me because
there are many ways you can decline
something that are likely to upset
someone or don't do anything to offset
the potential for someone being upset I
came away from receiving this
just laughing and wanting to get better
at writing polite declines because I
felt better about you I respected you
more after receiving that
how did you learn to
write how did you improve or develop
your written communication
I can't believe you pulled that letter
out that's wild
and you know what I do that almost every
day
but I wouldn't do it if it wasn't if it
weren't genuine I wouldn't have gone to
the trouble of saying all that stuff if
it weren't genuine you know yeah
I've always loved writing my dad
was an amazing editor he was actually
the managing editor of
the newspaper at Princeton the daily
princetonian and he took great pride in
marking up anything I ever wrote
you know I care I love writing I love
expressing myself but I also I think
more to your point it's it's not the
quality of the writing as much as it is
the sentiment behind it which is that
yes if somebody
gets back to what we were saying earlier
if somebody cared enough to reach out
their hand and say I want to shake hands
with you
that's what that was or they reach out
to give you a hug
what are you going to do just become a
tree and not hug them back
and and I think that I've learned a very
very important lesson in fact I'd be
curious and you'll probably know
I care so much about
letting someone know if I do appreciate
an invitation but I just genuinely can't
do it
I care that they know that that their
imitation mattered to me so much so that
I sometimes procrastinate writing that
note and I've learned the hard way yeah
that
that sometimes my mind and my heart are
at war with each other
my mind knows I shouldn't do it my heart
really wants to do it and if that
translates to making you or Jeffrey wait
too long to get that response it doesn't
really matter what I wrote so I'm really
curious to know when when Jeff's
invitation came and how many days went
by before I responded my bed is more
days than there should have been
hahaha
I don't have the dates but I'll take a
look
has your approach to that type of polite
decline changed over time do you have
other language that you like to use and
again this is not to imply to your point
earlier that this is disingenuous like
the assumption is made and I believe
that it's just it's really hard but have
you found it's it's just really it takes
time because
you know what what most people do sadly
is they just delete the invitation
or they just ignore it
um
so I think it kind of falls into a
couple of camps here so number one is
is this something I really want to do
number two if I really want to do it can
I do it so that's easy look at your
calendar
and number three
is this something that I feel like I
should do
and and then of the shoulds there's
another couple buckets which is is it a
should because I have to or is it
because
it should because it's good
right I've gotten into most trouble on
the shoulds
if I really really want to do something
like I really wanted to have this
conversation with you today I'm the guy
that reached out to you
and
I love when I get a spark of something
that I really want to do
but
many many times the invitations come in
I get a lot from politicians we use
support this or that I get a lot from
you know speaking opportunities
Etc
and I'm not complaining I'm very very
fortunate
but if it's a should
I learned this lesson from the
restaurateur Jeremy King who's in London
a great guy
and he said
he said the shoulds are what have gotten
me in the most trouble and I ask myself
a simple question
if this thing were tonight
because it's generally something you
know four five six months from now but
if this thing were tonight is this
something I would be excited to do or
would I roll my eyes and go oh man look
what I have to do tonight and so by
making it in the very present that's
really helped me a lot with the shoulds
and then
I just feel like it's not my obligation
to say yes to everybody but I do care I
genuinely care if somebody had the
courtesy to invite me to do something
they deserve the courtesy of a
gracious response all they're guilty of
is saying I'm interested in you how bad
is that that's that's a compliment